what's up guys Michael here now like
everyone else who exists mostly on the
internet I've been watching the two most
hyped up shows of the year the Lord of
the Rings the rings of power and House
of the Dragon these shows have a lot in
common they're both continuations
popular fantasy books that gained
massive popularity and adaptations they
both feature bleach blonde baddies and
they've both explore themes and
characters established in the original
films and series but maybe most
importantly they're both prequels and
there was a time
when the world was so young
they had not yet been a sunrise
but even then
there was light
life this might not seem like a big deal
but we think this is what makes these
shows so relevant to our current moment
is this because we're worried about
being cooked by a dragon or obscured by
an orc not so much it has more to do
with how we can't seem to stop thinking
about the end of the world and lucky for
us there's some philosophers who think
that thinking about the apocalypse might
actually be a good thing we'll explain
in this wisecrack Edition on the rings
of power and House of the Dragon how is
the world going to end in case you're
waiting to watch both shows while
avoiding your family this Thanksgiving
here's the deal the rings of power is
the super expensive pet project of Jeff
Bezos that doesn't look like a giant
penis it's a prequel to The Lord of the
Rings trilogy taking place about 5 000
years before Frodo ever took his furry
feet out of the Shire or Hobbits as we
know them even existed for that matter
because of the time Gap the only
familiar faces are some of our Elven
friends because these pointy ear nerds
live basically forever and unlike the
Peter Jackson films the rings of power
isn't based on a single book or story
instead it's primarily based on the
appendices from the original book now
the show is legally unable to use
material from the silmarillion and
cannot continue the Lord of the Rings or
Hobbit stories so it introduces a lot of
new characters but it's mostly oriented
around the looming threat of our old
buddy Sauron House of the Dragon which
takes place about 200 years before the
events of Game of Thrones is based on
the book Fire and Blood by George R.R
Martin his middle initials stand for rum
and Robitussin his favorite cocktail
please don't drink that because I feel
like then I'd be legally responsible for
your death it's more of a history book
than a novel and it's written by a
historian from within the Game of
Thrones Universe the show explores the
era before Daenerys targaryen's
ancestors lost all their power and all
their dragons but it has about the same
amount of incest and like the original
series the whole thing is marked by lots
of Whispers And Intrigue and also lots
of butts so why did both franchises go
the prequel route one answer is that
they're both based on wildly popular IP
that arguably had no way of moving
forward sequentially and of course
they're both basically guaranteed to
make HBO and Amazon tons of money as
they know we're just little piggies
hungry for content and we'll just slop
this [ __ ] up like our life depends on it
the more interesting answer is that
prequels when done well can give us a
new perspective on worlds and events
we're already familiar with and more
importantly in the instance of the Rings
of power and House of the Dragon they
give us a pre-apocalyptic view of
societies and worlds that we know are
headed for Apocalypse level events now
you might be thinking but a lot of
stories like this really matter when we
already know how things work out doesn't
this suck the dramatic tension out of
things now I hear you but a recent
sample to the contrary is the success of
the Breaking Bad prequel series Better
Call Saul even though everyone knew
where our guy saw was going to end up it
ended up being one of the most lauded
shows since well Breaking Bad in the
case of their rings of power and House
of the Dragon this format allows us to
better see how societies and groups in
power can go from states of prosperity
and stability into states of conflict
war and collapse and while this might in
some cases preclude the type of dramatic
tension we might normally associate with
shows like this I.E when we get stressed
precisely because we don't know what's
going to happen in the case of these
prequels we end up feeling something
closer to dramatic irony precisely
because we do know what's coming in the
future quick note on dramatic irony as a
storytelling term coined by Aristotle
and it describes the feeling of irony we
as an audience experience when we know
more than the characters it's like in
the Star Wars prequels when Padme starts
a romantic affair with a teenager but we
know that teenager will turn into Darth
Vader one day so she's both hooking up
with a teenager which is dark and Darth
Vader which is dramatic irony
but is there something especially
enjoyable about the dramatic irony of
watching these two stories where we feel
a sense of apocalyptic Doom looming just
around the corner because well we we
know it's going to happen in the future
well historically fantasy is similar to
sci-fi and that it organizes Societies
in ways that reflect our own world in
order to comment on it for example
Tolkien used fantasy to say stuff like
nature is good and industrialism is bad
others have used it to critique
bureaucracy or state power you know it's
like every story about a corrupt Kingdom
waiting for a good hero to show up and
save the day others use fantasy to
explore themes of race gender and
xenophobia but what they all do is build
Societies in relatively unsubtle ways
using clearly moral and immoral
characters thus making it easier for us
to identify problems in our own world so
what does this mean for fantasy stories
that explore the collapse of Societies
or apocalyptic events shows like this
are unique because taken in their whole
context we have a clear perspective on
the befores and afters of these events
while we know that things will go wrong
we're still not sure exactly how they
will go wrong and that's why right now
it feels like such a perfect moment for
these shows more so than in recent
decades it seems like we are
collectively looking towards the end of
the world we even did an entire video
about this so check it out things like a
once in a century Global pandemic
increasing effects of climate change
including more frequent catastrophic
weather events uh political unrest
Rising Fascism and continued economic
turmoil have lots of us thinking about
how it all might end we see this
reflected in many aspects of our culture
it's why we wanted to watch a movie that
was a thinly veiled allegory about
climate change killing us all or a
limited series about what the world
looks like after a devastating flu took
out most of the population while it
might seem extreme stories like these
end up being relatable as their
characters face down potentially
world-changing events and struggle to
cope with existence in their aftermath
they can also provide a sense of hope
I.E Middle Earth survived so maybe we
will too or at least a type of catharsis
I.E all societies fall apart eventually
right so uh hey at least we had a good
run but the difference between obsessing
over climate change and watching the
struggles of Westeros and Middle Earth
is that we know what's going to happen
in those places which adds a deeper
level of meaning and in some cases
Melancholy to our experience as viewers
when we're watching The pre-sauron Vibes
of Middle Earth or the dragon filled
Skies of Westeros we know that things
are about to turn to [ __ ] in a way that
the characters don't arguably this is
how the aliens that discover the shards
of our civilization will feel when they
realize that we knew things were falling
apart but just sort of let it happen
because of a profit and stuff in the
rings of power we get to experience the
full Glory of cause of Doom with all of
its signs of beauty and affluence but
simultaneously we know that this is
going to fall apart and we see a young
esilder slightly Reckless but seemingly
good-hearted and wanting to serve his
people but we know that this charming
young man will eventually screw
everything up
in House of the Dragon we see harrenhal
as a Place full of glory and power a
place where the heir to the Iron Throne
is named but we know that it's going to
turn into the Airbnb of castles before
it ends up completely abandoned and of
course there's the dragons we see King's
Landing full of lots and lots of dragons
but of course in the Westeros of Game of
Thrones at least initially dragons no
longer exist and the pits that used to
hold them are just relics from an
ancient past but in the real world which
for many feels about as bad as one big
version of Mordor we have no idea what's
going to happen after things get even
worse rather than the dramatic irony we
might experience seeing the elves create
the forge that Sauron will use to make
the Rings or seeing the targaryens run
around as if there's no Civil War around
the corner we instead get the
existential dread of knowing that
something bad is coming but having no
idea what it'll look like and what if
anything might exist on the other side
so is there a purpose in contemplating
the end of our world or at least the
potential for a world-changing
catastrophes other than just seeing how
quickly we can make ourselves have a
panic attack of course my record is 49
seconds for some philosophers and
political theologians It's actually an
intellectually productive thing to do
and they call it apocalyptic thought
this is the act of considering the
philosophical and Theological
implications of the end of the world at
least as we know it ending or changing
radically into something beyond that
which we can currently conceive
according to scholar Thomas Lynch a
apocalypticism is rooted in this
conviction that it is not just aspects
of the world but this world itself that
is unethical so the idea is that since
the world as a whole is unethical or
lacking we don't need to change the
world we need a new one it's sort of
like having an older car that is beyond
repair and then you finally accept that
you just got to scrap it and apply for a
lease at your local Kia dealership this
video is not brought to you by KIA if
they would like to sponsor us that would
be great we could use the cards they'll
have no idea what you mean but when
you're filling out the lease thing put
in discount code wisecrack and ask for
20 off your Kia Nero we see an example
of this albeit from the bad guy side of
things and the character Adar in the
rings of power he's the father of all
the Orcs And believing that Middle Earth
has failed as children he aims to
destroy the world as it currently exists
to create a new and very smoke-filled
world for all of his orc babies to
flourish imagine the cards he must get
on Father's Day presumably
they're all written with like black vile
and blood and but have really Earnest
messages from his children but according
to apocalyptic theorists in some cases
reflecting on how our current world
might end is actually a precondition for
thinking of what new world can be
created after that destruction and it's
worth noting that this apocalyptic
desire is usually happening in
opposition to a group or order who wants
to keep things precisely as they are
because of how it benefits them now if
you served them with late lady red wine
waiting cake
thank you
for example both sides of the
targaryen's Dynasty's desperate fight to
keep themselves in power at all cost as
Lynch writes in this case apocalypticism
is not so much the end of history but
the end of our history if apocalypse is
simultaneous Revelation and Annihilation
what is revealed are the gaps and
fissures which are the sites of a
destructive potential meaning that the
apocalypse isn't the end of the world
but the end of a particular formation of
the world and when he says that
apocalypse is both Revelation and
Annihilation this means that things
falling apart can often expose new
possibilities we may not have previously
seen it's sort of like how even though
things are going pretty poorly for much
of the original Lord of the Rings
trilogy in moments of seeming collapse
the Bros and the fellowship come
together in new ways pointing towards a
better possible future for Middle Earth
now you might be thinking hey isn't
apocalypse also a thing in the Bible and
you're not wrong as the last chapter of
God's autobiography The Book of
Revelation is like an acid-fueled
description of the world getting totally
blasted apart but this line of thought
doesn't end the Bible study there as
apocalyptic thinkers also utilize the
concept of messianism in religion
Messianic thought refers to the idea
that some type of Messiah often a
singular figure like Jesus Christ will
come at some point in the future to save
the world and bring about some New Order
marked by things like justice and peace
and it's no surprise that we see this
theme in the work of noted Catholic boy
J.R.R Tolkien who uses Messianic
characters like Frodo and Aragorn
according to Lynch here partially
quoting Roland IV messianism is a
subcategory of eschatology I.E the
Theology of the end of the world one in
which a particular individual divinely
appointed and directed affects the
transition from old to new so in this
way Messianic figures can be like the
captains of the Apocalypse Paving the
way for a new world and helping to
destroy the old one and while Messianic
themes might make more intuitive sense
in the stories of the Catholic Tolkien
George R.R Martin who does not strike me
as the church type has some very clear
Messianic themes in his own work for
example in the original Game of Thrones
series Jon and Daenerys both function as
chosen ones coming from outside the
current order to pave the way for a new
world to uh varying effects in this
sense both of them but especially
Daenerys can be seen as bringing about
an apocalypse while trying to create
something new so this isn't just a
concept for the religious or Middle
Earth adjacent as political and
especially Marxist philosophers have
also embraced this concept to think
about radical political change for
example German philosopher Ernst block
argued for a reading of Marxism as a
humanist utopianism now he thought that
all Freedom movements are Guided by
utopian aspirations
exemplified by things like the Messianic
parts of the Bible he wrote that
everywhere one looks the Messianic is
the last handhold of life and the
ultimate resultant of the light of
utopian truth which basically means that
the Messianic is what gives us hope in
the face of apocalyptic situations but
the closest most of us seem to get to
Messianic moments in the modern era is
usually during elections when we fall
under the collective if well-intentioned
delusion that some singular figure will
help Foster us into a new era and while
we might not have dragons and wizards
and socially acceptable incest in our
own world we have some other evil forces
lurking behind the scenes that make it
feel like any type of new world is
basically impossible okay guys you you
know where this is going so say it with
me capitalism as Thomas RR Lynch writes
there is a saying often attributed to
Frederick Jameson that it is easier to
imagine the end of the world than the
end of capitalism this sent is redundant
the end of capitalism would be the end
of the world there is no remainder not
positioned in relation to Capital there
are pre-capitalist para-capitalist and
post-capitalist forms of life and
exchange that are not yet capitalism or
resist capitalism yet these are all
still positioned in relation to Capital
also to be clear Lynch's middle initials
are not RR but it felt appropriate so uh
hopefully he forgives me but if not feel
free to complain in the comments just
like how Middle Earth can't find real
justice as long as Sauron and his Rings
exist and the people of Westeros seem to
be stuck with the Targaryen Dynasty as
long as their dragons fly it seems that
any modification or change which boils
down to capitalism but like different is
as useful as Sauron tweeting that black
lives matter and this is why our
pre-apocalyptic situation is one marked
by anxiety instead of melancholy as
while we know that eventually Sauron is
going to shut his eye for good we have
no idea what Better or Worse future we
have to look forward to but hey at least
we have great billionaires like Jeff
Bezos making TV shows to help keep us
distracted while he single-handedly
dismantles Society to extract maximum
profit while he plans his escape from
this Dying World in his dick ship but
what do you guys think are these fantasy
shows training us to think about the end
of the world in a productive way or are
we all just sickos that can't stop
watching shows about cousins who bang
let us know what you think in the
comments huge thanks to our patrons for
being part of our little Messianic cult
and be sure to check out our patreon
page if you haven't like this video to
show us that there is still hope in this
dark world and subscribe if you want to
do us a solid as always thank you so
much for watching and I say it every
time but it means a lot to us we
appreciate your support and we love you
guys see you later
[Music]